souvenez vous je viendrai ce est
précisément d'un quartier souvient
maison blanche de la madeleine une ville
de la banlieue lilloise 2 3 je viens de
gisors dans l'eure
et pourquoi avoir choisi l'animation
bien parce que je pense que il faut
situer les problèmes là où ils sont
c'est à dire à la base et l'animation
nous permet de voir les gens dans la
réalité quotidienne de leur vie et
éventuellement de leur permettre de
prendre conscience de leurs besoins et
de leurs possibilités
là où ils sont dans leur espace et dans
leur temps notre tâche ce pouvoir faire
travailler ensemble des gens de groupes
sociaux différents
j'ai choisi ce l'animation surtout après
une expérience de 5 ans dans l'industrie
où j'ai ressenti fortement le manque de
structures dans les dents les personnes
et je trouve que l'animation peut donner
à aux différentes personnes la charpente
qui leur manque
parce que le secteur socioculturel est
extrêmement important dans la vie
humaine
l'étude du milieu urbain
tel est le thème d'une session se
termine en actuellement à 3
essentiellement au centre de promotion
sociale et aussi dans la rue n'ayant
connu des précédents qu'à paris nancy
grenoble et rennes
cette expérience aura réuni des
représentants des académies de caen
rouen amiens lille et reims avec 25
participants dont 18 directeur de mjc
c'est en effet la fédération champagne
ardenne des mjc qui est à la base de
cette initiative être mises en oeuvre
par le tout récent centre de formation
inter régionale d'animateurs
socioculturels de 3 pour lequel michel
allenbach se passionna poser des
questions des fêtes de personnes ces
maladies partout et pas pour le thème
général du travail c'est l'affluence
mais l'achitecture complètement sociale
des gens alors à partir de là on
voudrait résumer toutes les requêtes qui
ont été faites
constituant un des cinq sous groupes de
travail mis en place par l'ensemble des
stagiaires
ces jeunes gens comme dans les autres
groupes de l'éclatement ont géré eux
mêmes leur programme d'activités en
l'occurrence dans le quartier des
chartreux il s'agit à l'aide
d'interviews d'analyser la structuration
de l'espace sur la vie sociale des
abymes avoir des voisins
wibox aline bonjour bonsoir évidemment
on n'a pas le temps de plaisanter mais
pas des gens pour la dh par exemple
talent et la douche témoin pense que les
gens se gardent facilement leurs enfants
oui oui l'esprit ce qui nous a parlé
dans un gros problème
scolaire qui va être maman c'est
beaucoup d'écoles dans le schéma de jeu
construite la nouvelle
dans le couple a new des landes à vous
paraît suffisant pout but mon équipe est
jeune c'est pour vous dire que c'est
mort pour moi le problème et son frère
lui j'ai un fils de 16 ans mais il va à
l'école
libre après alors pour vous un problème
à ce soir-là et votre fiche de saison
par exemple qu'est ce qu'il fait pendant
ses loisirs il va droit où ils restent
ici monde entier remarquez il n'y a pas
de maison de jeunes il n'y a pas de
signe allemagne impact est réservée aux
séries peut-être
les cinq sous lé bureau pourront
interroger les habitants afin de
collecter un maximum d'indications à
travers un échantillonnage de population
s'il m'en fallait pas très fournie
chanteuse se déranger a droit c'est
samedi lorsque venus sur très cher
évidemment les comme tout le monde en
veut pas se permettre d acheter
on nous dit d'aller à 3 parce que s'il
n'y a rien et c'est une bibliothèque
annexe ou six
et si vous demandiez si les propositions
à la bibliothécaire de des chartreuses
auquel vous face à porter les rangées
suivant la semaine d'après alors que le
ca d'environ libre au lycée technique
d'état toujours aux chartreux
la question qui est imposé à très bien
sûr aux loisirs des jeunes est ce que
vous trouvez parricide et des
équipements de type maison du jeune
cinéma
abordant le lycée alors oui d'accord
quand les sous-groupes reviennent qui de
la chapelle saint luc qui du vieux
troyes c'est la réunion collective avec
confrontation des informations
recueillies par fois auprès des élus ou
des techniciens et c'est aussi la séance
de travail avec un sociologue ou entre
stagiaires
il y à une interférence entre donc la
cité le local et le régional il ya notre
interférences qui se situe entre le
régional et national
le national avec le sixième plan de la
politique nationale il ya aussi une
interférence entre le domaine local la
cité hélène nationale directement
il y a aussi des interférences entre eux
ces trois secteurs et une dimension
européenne qui sont à des échelles plus
ou moins grande
assez faible pour le local un peu plus
fantôme régional est forte pour le
national tout cela est en fête
sur régis par le politique c'est à dire
qui décide quoi cette session avait deux
déterminer d'une part analysé la ville
sociales existantes et savoir comment la
développer
d'autre part définir une méthode
d'approché pour réaliser une étude des
milieux l'an vue de la formation de
travailleurs sociaux et de l'animation
permanente dans les quartiers je crois
tous des conceptions très différentes de
ce que c'est que l'animation mais je
crois que ce qui est très important dans
le travail que nous faisons là c'est de
voir que chacun la recherche sa manière
et le groupe dont je fais partie plutôt
le sous groupe s'efforce essentiellement
de voir comment l'information
peut-être un processus privilégié de
cette animation
et quand nous avons su que vous veniez
nous avons eu beaucoup plus envie non
pas d'être interviewé par vous que de
vous interviewer pour vous demander
notamment comment vous concevez cette
animation par la télévision
cette information oui bien pour nous la
télévision c'est susciter quelque chose
c'est à dire que nous avons début d'une
part j'ai dit tout à leur rendre service
c'est peut-être une façon de s'exprimer
peut-être un peu brutal il en use ou
voudrions voir deux prolongements à
l'information la formulation qu'est la
télévision
d'une part nous aimerions rendre service
dans la mesure où nous faisons connaître
votre action car elle mérite selon les
critères qui sont les nôtres d'être
connu et d'autre part nous informons les
personnes qui pourraient être concernées
par ce que vous faites que elles seront
intéressés un jour ou l'autre par ce
fait qu'ils gravent brutale tristes ou
joyeux